great wanna take a selfie real quick yes
there was actually hold on everyone
don't edit d-roc all right you got it
how's my friend you look amazing thank
you though you did it you really loved
it all right tell everybody you tell the
Vayner nation who you are 5 in our
nation I'm ally to Castro Atmos LED on
Twitter so my question is I'm actually
really glad I'm asking it one on one and
not in front of the audience and now
that it's being filmed yeah just wait
huge anymore huge so um I have a job
that I absolutely love I actually worked
for Remax of New Jersey who spoke for us
yeah be much right before I got hired so
I just missed you um I love my job I
love what I do
I do social media and graphic design I
work with our SEO company we develop
content and of course I want to get into
doing my own thing during my own blog
starting my own hustle and I have this
and I know it stems from a fear of
failure but I have this really hard time
I get like crippled when it comes to
like executing and I know you're
probably seems like just do it go for it
do your thing and I know so well but I
just need to hear it like I need you to
look me in my teeth and tell me what do
you want it yes I do and so literally
you're just scared to fail I mean if you
want to go deep with me I'll go deep you
know who are you scared to fail in front
of is it your mom is your best friend is
your sister that's the only thing to
hold you people back
something happened to me like everybody
thinks like oh I'm so nice look at what
I'm doing right now through this I don't
give a [ __ ] about anybody else's opinion
so Rallye that I'm never scared because
if I fail and people like see huh I'm
like I don't even it doesn't even
register it doesn't in the same way when
people like you change my life they're
the best I'm able to be grounded because
it also doesn't it you know kind of in
that middle zone right like not too high
not too low which would confuse people
based on my energy but I equally care
about every comment in the YouTube
section of this episode I'm gonna read
them but if somebody says you blow and
like this format stinks and you should
let d-roc at it you know it's gonna be
okay
like and so if you want to get deep with
me I know for a fact that you're if
because you've already given it to me
that it's to feel fair a feeling of the
fear of failure now the question becomes
to whom and what I would do is and
you'll have to share that with the world
I'd go talk to that person up front the
best practical advice I've ever given
this scenario and it works over and over
is you go and you sit down with that and
say or Johnny or your boyfriend or your
sister or your girlfriend I don't care
who it is right you sit down you look
them in the face to say I'm about to do
this and the only reason I haven't done
it for the last year is I don't want to
let you down because entrepreneurship is
a crapshoot and I'm not sure if I'm
gonna win but long-term I'm gonna win
and I just need to make sure if I fail
on this step that your response to me
doesn't crush me to never let me have a
second at-bat that's what it is okay
right yes that's it you got oh crap wait
subscribe do you I need subscriptions
because I can't push this many right
hooks in social